euh mon Stéphane qui sort du silence il
est accusé de violence conjugale par
plusieurs de ses excagnes mais on a des
infos Gill vous avez des infos exclusif
vraiment Gilles et ce sont des vrais
infos he Gilles vraiment vraiment moi ai
j'ai des vra infos ou mais lui
[Rires]
ili il a vas-y donne tes infos mais lui
il a vraiment eu il a il a d on doute
pas que vous ayz voà allez-y alors
allez-y parce que on aura les infos VO
alors je sais pas si les gens ont vu
mais là depuis quelques jours hein
depuis samedi s du silence Stéphan
Plazza est sorti du silence alors il
fait de de jolies phrases sur Instagram
où il remercie son public il il se la
joue à moitié philosophe et cetera là
aujourd'hui il vient de dire que voilà
c'est la reine pour enfoncer les gens
non
philosopheend la su je te promets
attends la su et donc là il remercie son
public et il dit que voilà il est
confiant que la justice va va sauver son
son honneur et cetera et pourquoi il dit
ça pourquoi depuis depuis quelques jours
Stéphane Plazza revient un peu sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est parce que
effectivement moi les infos que j'ai
c'est que l'enquête avance plutôt en sa
faveur ouais tu vois c'est
positif avance plutôt en sa faveur et
que l'histoire du complot semble
vraiment se se dessiner et comme vous le
savez il y a trois plaintes aussi pour
harcèlement qui ont été déposé par des
jeunes femmes qui se sont dit harcelé
par les victimes supposées de Stéphane
Plaza et du coup comme la la l'enquête
avance plutôt dans son sens faut savoir
quand même que Stéphan plazade n'a
toujours pas été entendu par la police
donc ils estiment que les faits sont pas
aussi euh enfin ça demande pas une alors
myiam Gilles a a des infos exclusives
qui vient d'avoir de de cet après-midi
oui alors l'enquête effectivement contre
Stéphane Plaza avance mais elle avance
moins vite que l'enquête qui est liée à
la plainte que Stéphane Plaza a déposé
pour cyberhcèlement et là les enquêteurs
sont en train de remonter les faux
profils parce que ce ce sont des faux
profils selon lui qui ont commencé à le
harceler donc il faut maintenant établir
si ces faux profils sont liés aux femmes
qui ont porté plainte contre lui ça
c'est une possibilité alors évidemment
s'il a commis des violences il doit être
condamné il y a pas de souci mais il y a
une 4rième plainte qui vient d'être
déposée qui est très sérieuse contre les
femmes qui l'ont cyber arcelé ça fait
maintenant quatre plaintes et ces
plaintes elles étaient au départ
contreix mais elles portent les noms des
gens qui sont derrière les faux profils
et si jamais il s'avère Infiné que
Stéphane Plaza n'est pas condamné que
par exemple on a voulu le harceler qu'on
a voulu lui nuire ça pourrait coûter
très cher aux gens qui l'ont cber
harcelé pourquoi parce que les
franchisés en ce moment sont en chute
libre et ces franchisés il versent 8 %
de redevance et ces franchisés ont
décidé d'attaquer d'attaquer les gens
qui ont cyberhcelé si jamais c'est gens
sont retrouvés et si jamais Stéphane
Plaza gagne ce volet là ces gens vont
être attaqués par les franchisés et ça
va leur coûter une fortune parce que le
préjudice économique le préjudice
économique est c'est tout à fait
normal une source de dossier m'a dit si
jamais il est établi que c'était
vraiment du cyberhcèlement et si on
retrouve derrière les faux profils les
identités ce qui est possible ces
gens-là vont se retrouver sur la paille
donc c'est une affaire qui peut se
retourner c'est une affaire où il y aura
très bientôt du nouveau et les sommes
vont se chiffrer en millions d'euros
c'estàd qu'on va demander à des gens si
ces gens sont retrouvés de payer des
millions d'euros de dommage donc voilà
Stéphan Plaza en ce moment encore une
fois je ne préjuge pas de l'issue du de
la première plainte lui la situation est
voilà il va il va très mal il est il est
isolé il tente de se reconstruire
évidemment c'est difficile il suit ça
très près mais le volet cyberhcèlement
prend une dimension que l'on ne
soupçonnait pas Cyr voilà très bien
merci es derrière merci à vous deux en
tout cas merci qui reviendra demain
parce qu'on a d'autres infos P qui tombe
et demain il y a un très gros dossier
qui va tomber ok en juin et juillet
dernier on va revenir sur cette affaire
le réalisateur Nicolas Bodos a été
accusé de viol et d'agression sexuelle
par trois femmes une enquête
préliminaire avait été ouverte ces trois
femmes ont témoigné après que
l'animateur é accusé
regardez depuis plusieurs mois Nicolas
bedo s'est visé par une enquête il
s'agit d'une enquête qui a été ouverte
le 5 juillet dernier pour viol et
agression se alors que l'homme est
réalisateur sera prochainement convoqué
devant le tribunal correctionnel pour
agression sexuelle en état d'ivresse
dans une boîte de nuit dans le cadre
d'une autre affaire plusieurs femmes ont
en juillet dernier porté de lourdes
accusations à son encontre il lui aurait
demandé avec insistance de monter dans
sa chambre elle aurait refusé Nicolas
Bedos a été entendu la semaine dernière
en tant que suspect libre dans cette
enquête pour viol myiam Palomba nous
explique tout ce soir dans
TPMP merci Myriam alors Nicolas bedau S
entendu dans le cadre d'une enquête pour
viol oui oui alors il a été la semaine
dernière entendu dans dans une dans une
enquête pour viol et agression sexuelle
par le premier district de de police
judiciaire c'est en fait il faut que je
vous explique un peu l'histoire parce
que en fait leseffit remonte au 1er et 2
juin dernier ou dans une discothèque
parisienne sauvage pour pour pas la
citer Nicolas bed c'est une discothèque
c'est tu sais la quelle c'est ouais
c'est quoi sauvage sauvage d'accord
voilà dans le quartier déal donc donc là
Nicolas bedose qui était visiblement
assez é méché aurait agressé une jeune
femme de 25 ans il sera allé sur la
piste de danse il lui aurait mis la main
entre les jambes et du coup elle
l'aurait repoussé il elle lui aurait dit
mais tu tu es fou toi et cetera et elle
aurait dit tu es
foumoi dismoi c'était ma cousine ou quoi
dis-moi tu es fou toi ou quoi je vais
tcinter tu es
fouurait dit tu es fou voilà c'est ça
donc elle lui a dit tu es fou va-t-en et
cetera et puis du coup elle a été portée
plainte le 12 juin et le 22 juin Nicolas
Bedos est donc mis en garde à vue suite
à cette histoire alors là il reconnaît
pas vraiment les fait dit que c'est que
s'il y a eu effectivement attouchement
c'était accidentel il était bourré et
cetera il s'excuse donc là l'OPJ lui
remet une convocation il devait être jug
il doit être jugé pour ses fait
d'agression sexuel sous l'effet de
l'alcool au mois de février prochain les
choses auraient pu là sauf que TR femmes
ont ont envoyé des signalements au
parquet et le parquet comme les fait
pour tous ne sont
pas prescrit a décidé de prendre
l'affaire en main même si elle ces trois
femmes n'ont pas déposé plainte et ce
sont des faits qui dont certains sont
qualifiés de viol d'accord ouis donc
c'est c'est sérieux oui c'est très
sérieux alors il y a a une jeune enfin
une jeune femme maintenant elle a 50 ans
qui qui parle al c'est elle qui qui
parle de viol les fait remontent dans
les Ann en 1999 elle était à avec
Nicolas Bedos il l'invite à une soirée
la soirée se continue il lui propose
d'aller chez lui chez ses parents à nei
et là il lui propose de monter dans sa
chambre il lui aurait proposé de monter
dans sa chambre c'est ce qu'elle dit
évidemment elle refuse parce qu'elle
sent bien que quelque chose se passe il
l'aurait attrapé par la gorge en lui
disant mais tu te prends pour qui toi tu
es quand même pas Catherine de neuve
là-dessus il l'aurait forcé à aller dans
sa chambre et là aurait eu un acte non
sexuel non consenti avec avec cette
jeune femme il y a une autre femme aussi
qui qui parle qui qui qui qui a fait un
signalement en racontant que elle elle
était adolescente au moment des faits
hein c'était en 2016 c'était dans dans
une maison de vacances où elle éta
invitée par Nicolas Bedos et sa compagne
de l'époque et là pareil alors là c'est
plus du du ressort de l'agression
sexuelle il aurait pareil enfin il
aurait voulu l'embrasser de force elle
se serait débatue et puis bon ça ça en
serait resté là et il y a aussi un
troisième témoignage d'une autre jeune
femme qui est là explique que elle c'est
dans le casadre d'une soirée où il y
avait des artistes une soirée un peu
cinéma un peu showbiz et cetera et que
là pareil il l'aurait forcé à aller à la
coincer dans les toilettes et qui pareil
il aurait voulu l'embrasser il lui
aurait touché le ventre et cetera enfin
il y aurait eu des attouchements donc
ces trois signalements qui sont quand
même des des défits assez graves le
parquet a décidé de pas les prendre à la
légère et et aujourd'hui entamer une
enquête alors c'est une audition libre
pourquoi parce que contrairement à la
garde à vue il aurait pu partir à tout
moment mais effectivement dans cette
dans cette histoire il est quand même
considéré comme suspect d'accord g c'est
une circonstance aggravante par rapport
à la première affaire et le jugement en
février parfois on pense que non mais le
le fait de commettre une agression
sexuelle en état desbéé est une
circonstance aggravante et vous pouvez
risquer jusqu'à 7 ans de prison hein son
procès en février il risque gros Cyril
alors